ce matin aux abords du tribunal de
toulouse ils étaient une trentaine un
tour d'odile morin venu lui porter
soutien avant son passage dans le juste
cette gilet jaune en fauteuil roulant
avait bravé l'interdît en novembre
dernier elle était allée manifester
malgré l'interdiction
la présidente de l'association ni social
a été condamné à 1500 euros d'amendé
dont 1000 avec sursis
une condamnation que la principale
intéressée trouve injuste elle doit de
nouveau se présenter au tribunal le 23
mars écoutez là on m'a accusé de
violences sur des policiers
alors même que j'avais moins été
violenté avec 5 fracture du pied à la
clé une trentaine hématomes sur tout le
corps est alors que j'avais des preuves
de mon innocence et la culpabilité de la
police s'est malgré tout moi qui était
condamné par un juge qui a refusé
d'examiner les preuves de mon innocence
et donc j'ai été manifester parce que
les personnes handicapées sont
considérés comme des morts acceptable en
cas de tri pour les accès au service de
réanimation dans le cadre de l'accord
vide après avoir respecté l'interdiction
pendant onze mois
j'ai craqué quand quand j'ai vu que
j'étais considéré comme une mort
acceptable et que je risquais de finir
morte parce qu'on aurait refusé en
réanimation moi et mes camarades